associate director of the Simons
Institute
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with the Simons Institute we are the
international leading venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science and we bring together
the world's leaders in theoretical
computer science and related fields from
all over the world and Foster the next
generation of young scholars we were
established in 2012 with a generous gift
from the Simons Foundation
and the primary aim of our programs is
to explore algorithmic thinking and
science and engineering and also just to
study the laws of computation itself
so we're very grateful to the Simon's
foundation for their ongoing support and
to our highly valued industry Partners
algorand Apple Google JPMorgan NTT
research Rock 360 and VMware and their
support enables us to produce excellent
programs like we're going to have
tonight
also a big thank you to our donors in
our first annual uh Financial Campaign
which happened in December and as
mentioned in the appeal the Simon's
Foundation has generally offered to
match gifts one to one and if you're
interested in donating
feel free to reach out and contact me so
today's lecture is our theoretically
speaking series which highlights
exciting advances in theory theoretical
computer science for a general audience
um wow people are still piling in and
we're really excited to feature a
lecture today by potion low
so um Poe keeps a very active lecture
schedule I looked at his itinerary of
where he's been recently and where he's
going and I was exhausted just reading
the list
um he uh indeed reaches over 10 000
people through his lectures uh that he
gives around the globe and his the
videos that he's either created or
featured in have reached over 19 million
views on the YouTube channel so that's a
lot
um so Poe's date job is a professor of
mathematics at CMU he's also a math
coach part Excellence so he um he led
the CMU math team to their first uh
number one ranking among North American
universities he also coaches the U.S
math Olympiad team and led them to their
first back-to-back victories and 2015
and 16 and then again 18 and 19. so a
lot of um a lot of Victories there um
she's also an incredibly creative
innovator in the realm of education and
health care
and he started out creating just a an
Innovative learning platform but it's
grown well beyond that to all kinds of
projects in social welfare and health
Poe will do a much better job than I
will do in describing those so I'm going
to hand it over to him and his talk
today is about building human
intelligence at scale to save the Next
Generation from chat GPT thank you
[Applause]
yo hello everyone let me first check is
the is the level of this is the
microphone on it's the first question
yes oh well then you guys have wonderful
Acoustics in this room because I don't
hear myself so that's you guys have good
investments in this space uh first of
all I think I should say when I was told
to come here I was expecting a general
audience but I will say looking at the
audience
I I see some people here such as
somebody who taught me when I was in
school he was my coach I see I see
former students of mine I see other
esteemed professors I'm not slightly
wondering exactly what general audience
means
Institute but that's okay I I will I
will try to make this thing Broad and
hopefully interesting uh we will not
necessarily go into things that are too
specialized although because I see that
there are people in this audience who
might like geeking out over a few things
I might geek out over a few things at
times actually it's a real pleasure for
me to be here in Berkeley giving a talk
I don't think I've ever given a talk in
Berkeley before that was run by Berkeley
uh but I was born right around here so
so actually this is this is quite quite
fun to be here my father was a PhD
student in statistics and he graduated
in 1982. and so for me Berkeley has
always been a place that he said at some
point you should you should go study
there well I didn't quite well I'm happy
to be here for this now I I should also
say that the the objective of this talk
it's actually not around the computer
science behind GPT there are plenty of
people in this room who know far more
than I do about machine learning uh and
all of the artificial intelligence and
everything what I'm going to be focusing
on is what should we do next because I
work with the Next Generation I work
with education and in fact even this
morning I was actually just at a middle
school in fact what I what I like to do
I travel around because I want to
understand the problem one of the things
I've learned when trying to solve real
world problems Is that real world
problems involve real people and the
only way to understand how to solve real
people's problems is to talk to real
people so and so for example this
morning I was down at the middle school
actually talking to sixth grade seventh
grade eighth grade you name it down in
uh in in the Silicon Valley side of the
Bay
now for this for this talk I I'm going
to focus on education because I think
the the big thing that we're thinking
about right now in education is actually
GPT chat GPT so I'm going to Dive Right
In and start outlining why we have a
major problem and of course some of you
many of you may already know this but
the only way to know for sure is to go
and start asking some questions so I
like to give talks live uh there was a
warning that popped up earlier when I
opened this website saying that GPT is
under a heavy load right now so if this
if the live part doesn't work I'll just
tell you what it usually says does that
sound good but this is at least supposed
to be like so I want to tell the story
and the story starts from why I started
to worry about this you see at the
beginning I heard about this GPT thing
and I remember at the beginning the
beginning is November 2020 like last
last November all of us mathematicians
were busy mocking it saying I can't do
math this is at least what I overseeing
people were on marketing and saying I
can't do math but uh it was it was clear
that it could do some other things for
example you could write College
admission essays
actually that's the very first thing I
ever asked GPT to do because I was on a
scholarship Review Committee inside my
University it was the the Goldwater
scholarship Review Committee you know
what I'm talking about we were supposed
to nominate some candidates for
consideration for the national
competition and I've warned my
colleagues I said you know there's this
new GPT thing it can write essays so the
very first thing I did is I asked it to
write assets and discovered that it
could
actually this is going to shake up the
entire U.S higher education college
application system I I was at I was at a
talk I go to a lot of these a lot of
these places and give talks so I was I
was at an event at Yale there was a math
competition at Yale so I was speaking
about stuff to the parents and then
afterwards a Yale admission officer came
to to tell us all to have our kids apply
to Yale which you know we respect is
good and and the person gave some
opportunity for us to ask questions so
the students all asked questions and
then finally I wanted to ask my question
which was uh if you have chat GPT how
are you going to
deal with college essays next year the
admission officer said oh chat GPT can't
write good assets
please write the email admission essay I
like math
I also like computers
and I like hamburgers right with great
Passion not really fancy big words but
sound like I really am passionate about
helping people
and computers
it's not bad
I have no idea what it's gonna say I
just don't always say something
reasonable okay so it's not bad it's not
bad and this was one of my first
experiences that oh Chachi TT is going
to shake up the U.S higher education
industry for college admissions that's
interesting
this is pretty good
it's pretty good okay by the way
I mean some of you might also work in
the admission or advising on admission
and as far as I understand one of the
goals of the of the essay was to make it
so people can't apply to that many
colleges
actually when I think about the the
purpose of each piece of the College
admission this this helps to reduce the
number of colleges people apply to but
when you can generate the essay in five
seconds that's a different question uh
please by the way I know this is being
recorded so please if you're watching
this I am not endorsing the use of chat
GPT for cheating on college applications
uh please do not do that I I'm saying
this as a white hat hacker of saying
this is a this is an exploit so we need
to rethink what we're going to do with
college admissions given that you can do
all of this stuff okay so that was one
of the things then another thing that
happened that caused me to start paying
a little bit of attention because by the
way I didn't know I could actually do
this but not bad and then the next thing
that hit me was that I was talking to
somebody who worked in private equity
private Equity is uh what do you do in
private Equity you buy companies and
then you sell companies
yes
and you buy high sell low
no the opposite you you buy you buy low
sell high right and why is it low
oh buy high sell higher that's as long
as the sell is higher than the value
that's fine but the main question is
like you know why why is it low in the
first place usually in private Equity
you buy the
it could be startups it could also be
distressed companies or generally
companies that are about to go bankrupt
so I was talking to this this guy who
now runs the company that his PE private
Equity Firm but and so uh he's supposed
to do something to fix the company what
do you think you're supposed to do with
a fixer company if you bought one that
is uh losing money
ah you cut right to the chase lay off
people okay so he was we were just
chatting and he was talking about how he
had he had just asked his uh his
marketing team to find a more efficient
way to write the blog post for search
engine optimization because he had just
heard about this chat GPT so he'd asked
the marketing team why don't you just
use strategy to write the blog post and
it was so much faster and then the
marketing team started to wonder
about their jobs
because if the guy who was brought in
with one goal what's his goal
to lay off people is running around
telling various people in various
departments try using chat GPT to do
your job
kind of scary right so okay so that was
the next thing that hit but I was
thinking that won't touch my life okay I
I don't write blog posts I also don't
have to apply to college anymore and I
don't have to read the college essays so
this is all other people's problems and
then the times that hit me was when I
came back from winter break that was
January and there was a Carnegie Mellon
first year student who came to chat with
me about what he had done during winter
break and he told me
he spent his winter break writing a
program
and the program
well he first made an account on
tutor.com
you can probably see where this is going
so he made an account on twitter.com
then he wrote a program tutor.com by the
way is a website that you can use to get
questions answered you pay to get your
question answered and if you answer the
question you get paid very simple
concept the questions and all the
discussion are through chat only hint
hint so then guess what he did so his
program was connected in and so when the
question came in from tutor.com
he said there's a charging video now
this is a this is a smart guy okay he's
one of our undergrads we have some alums
of our wonderful undergrad institutions
sitting around here and so he was he was
one of our one of our undergrads so he
knew don't just ask Chachi PT to answer
the question he said answer it as if
you're a tutor
you know by the way that's not that hard
it's basically like you you feeded it
with a function you applied a very
simple function to the input and he
passed the function in and the thing
comes back and then he was also quite
clever he took the response and he
passed it back into chat GPT saying
please double check
that's a good move by the way because if
you have played the GPT for a while
sometimes the first thing it gives is
wrong now if it failed to double check
it texted him so then he manually
answered the question
it passed then
we went straight to the the person and
he told me he made 600 before he got
shot down for a violating terms of
service
so when I heard that I thought six
hundred dollars is a lot of money so
that means that he fooled 600 worth of
people
by the way you don't earn 600 in 10
minutes on tutor.com do you know what I
mean like his thing must be fairly legit
how in the world did this thing survive
and earn 600 because my impression was
chat GPT can't do math because all of
our math people were just making fun of
it right and if he can survive long
enough to make 600 600 bucks without
saying some nonsense then it must be
pretty good
so that's when I started looking at chat
GPT and asking it math questions and I
found out
it's not bad
okay here's a typical question you might
ask tutor.com
solve x plus 2 equals seven to solve the
equation x plus two equals seven you
need to isolate the variable X now it
shows all your work
this is pretty good I actually just gave
a talk at the middle school and I
explained this thing shows your work the
teachers were actually very enthusiastic
because they're always telling the
students you should show your work this
thing shows your work okay by the way
this thing I didn't get so excited so I
mean this thing I said okay okay that's
fine I I could imagine that maybe maybe
something like this is believable now
I'm just going to up fool it right okay
all right
now what if you accidentally
added to to both sides of the equation
instead
I was like this no way I can answer this
oh
actually it answers like how I would
talk wait a second what about my job
I don't know if you can see the words
coming across it's like
it's fairly legit
okay I disagree with this part I
disagree with this part right the
problem is that sometimes what it says
is not entirely correct the danger is
that it's hard to tell
okay that's actually we're going to get
towards that because I'm soon going to
be talking about what we need to do next
however what I want to say is that I've
also noticed depending on what what time
of day you ask there's always some
Randomness quite often it's actually
okay and usually what I see is that the
error rate there is an error rate but
the error rate is not not extraordinary
high that we I mean it's low enough that
I'm scared of it in the sense that this
thing is able to actually do some kinds
of teaching okay so then I started
looking at this and saying well now it
even hit my industry my industry is
education I teach people things so if
you made 600 from someone in my industry
I should probably care
because it's the year 2023 I hope to be
still in this industry for the next 20
years
and how good is this thing going to get
right
and then on March 14th there was gpt4
so then I got a little bit more curious
because when that came out people said
it was good actually the thing that made
me realize that I should probably pay
more attention is because when the uh
when the research result came out well
when when they're when their
advertisement came out
um they showed how it did on various
exams so this is this is the actual
visual from the gpt4 guys and what this
visual says is the height of the bar is
how high of a percentile the the GPT
scores or ranks on a lot of standard
exams there is better of course 100 is
the maximum percentile means compared to
all of the people in the world what
percent of those people are you better
than the scary thing is it's pretty high
on a lot and the blue is the old gbt 3.5
the green is gpt4 and gpt4 of course is
more sophisticated it was able to take
people from or take this thing on uh the
tool but they try to do the AP Chemistry
exam went from like about 20th
percentile to about 70th percentile of
humans the part that I found interesting
was not any of these APS
when I recorded I'd be more careful
exactly what I say about my feelings
about various assessments so I'll say no
further things about those but there's a
there's a there are some other exams at
the far end which are very very low
scores those at the far end are AMC 10
and AMC 12 and code forces rating uh let
me quickly tell you what those are
because those happen to be quite
interesting
so the AMC are the American math
competitions that's how you eventually
select for people to go on to the United
States international math Olympia team
the common theme of those passions is
they're supposed to be different from
the textbooks at least that's what we
try to do when we make the questions so
there are committees which make these
questions which are specifically trying
to make non-textbook problems when you
go and make AP exam usually it's
supposed to be a textbook problem I mean
usually it's supposed to be something
you've learned how to do SAT also
supposed to be something something you
learn how to do AMC it's supposed to be
something you haven't seen before
and so you should not be surprised that
they used to be at the very very bottom
there was this strange a nominee anomaly
that on the AMC 12 it got to nearly 50th
percentile at this point I am actually
not 100 sure I believe that they was
able to do this and the data is clean
I'm not sure I believe that but um I
will say it got me curious enough to
start asking check GPT my own questions
about math which are harder so now let's
start playing with harder questions
because solving the equation x plus two
equals seven that's not that big of a
deal
all right let's do something harder
what is the sub
oh it knows it's an arithmetic series
that's nice here's the formula
this is by the way not super
sophisticated yet this is something that
you would learn if you went to high
school algebra right and it's actually
just working out the whole thing showing
every step by the way I'm also showing
this whole thing out because this should
call into question what are we teaching
our kids nowadays anyway
we are actually teaching our kids how to
do this thing and this thing is
outperforming them
a lot of kids when they think about math
class they think about learning how to
do a type of problem practicing a
certain way of doing it and then putting
it up okay so this is already able to
mechanically go through a lot of the
techniques actually a lot of times when
people think about education they think
about teaching you a method and then you
practice the method and then they teach
you another method you practice the
other method and so on
the reason cat GPT can do this is
because it has ingested teachers manuals
right the way that you train these large
language models is by feeding it
language and guess what all of these
standard arithmetic series problems
there are teachers manuals explaining
how to do that so in theory it should be
able to do that
another way to do this using one plus
two plus 50.
oh my there is
ah you can use the sum of the series 1
to 50. no this is series two four and so
on up to 100 is formed by multiplying
each Terminal 1 to 50 by two wait a
second what's going on here okay this
thing is pretty good
that was a little bit surprising for me
that that it can that I can do this but
maybe maybe there are some books out
there which also happen to have uh you
know happen to have this trick and
actually after I saw these kinds of
things where the tricks can be done in
this way and maybe also realize we used
to say that somebody is good at math if
they somehow know a lot of tricks well
of course that's not what we really say
but but people you a lot of people think
someone's good at math if they somehow
seem to know all the tricks
that's sort of like saying someone is
smart if they know all of Wikipedia does
that mean Wikipedia it's right well no
Wikipedia has larger storage capacity
than the average person and so what's
going on here is this has large pattern
recognizing capacity and I guess that's
a pattern but just going on on how
powerful this thing is let's just keep
going
this is the one that I threw this on
social media because this one blew my
mind
factorize it 99 this is a math contest
problem so there is a trick
anyone know how to do this this is this
is a really good question
of course you know because some of you
here are not the general public and so
so the thing about this audience is
seems like there's people not the
general public but uh usually when you
factorize a number you try dividing it
by lots of things and this is a
difficult question to do because if you
divide it by lots of things it takes
forever
that's interesting that's interesting so
that's wrong
that's right
but what I'm trying to say is that part
is here
that part is the part that surprising
okay
so is it a prime number
ah it's not a prime number
by the way normal people also make
mistakes
yeah yeah very good
is that your final answer
ah okay see I was trying to Gaslight it
into maybe saying no but yeah yeah okay
this thing's pretty good but actually by
the way there are probably enough
teachers manuals with this but I guess
one other thing that made me a bit
surprised something I saw you I saw this
uh on Sunday I was at a math contest in
New Jersey on Sunday so I'm just going
to throw this here because I thought
this was hilarious so they actually
could do this too uh there was a math
contest I was at and here's a question
on the math contest it was
um find whole numbers a let's call them
X and Y so that 30X plus 31 by plus 21
times no no 28 times 1 equals 365.
find whole numbers X and Y so that 30X
plus 31 by plus 28 times 1 is 365.
this is a math contest problem I won't
tell you that yet okay
good problem
it's a really good price so the ways to
do this you can use modular arithmetic
or whatever yeah you know let's go play
with this thing and it'll do it though
uh Brute Force weight okay Brute Force
this is by the way how I tried this out
when I saw this question at that math
contest I was I was on the screen I did
this right you know you do this thing
and okay now now you go like do some uh
some some you could do Brute Force
that's what it's doing there some people
did modular arithmetic okay now it's
gonna it's gonna crank this out well it
crank this out I'll give you a hint this
math contest was called the Monmouth
exploratory math Expo
so they're acronym for Monmouth
what's mean m-e-m-e
so this question is actually a bit of a
joke
oh okay it got it they got it they got
it so it solved this problem and by the
way so far actually this thing is
reacting
it's pretty smart or smart I don't want
to use that word I don't want to
anthropylure facts but it can do a lot
of things and that's why we need to
think about being careful oh let's let's
have it do something else this is a math
contest problem
so the numbers are special
is there
a clever way
and I thought on Sunday this would break
it and I was wrong
what the heck
[Laughter]
so by the way on Sunday I do a lot of
things live if you can tell I just do it
live because whenever I do it live I
just use whatever new input came in on
Sunday I was going to use this as my
example of the problem that is in no
textbook whatsoever because it was made
up by some random high school students
or the math contest called meme
who else would come up with a question
like this okay
this is the this is the best solution
this is actually how you're supposed to
do the problem that's why it was 28
times 5. okay
pretty good
yeah yeah I mean it works it works I
know that 365 days in a year so this
thing has to work ah it works okay after
I was giving this talk on Sunday and by
the end of this part actually a parent
raised her hand and said I used to not
be scared of GPT now I am because
actually there are a lot of people who
haven't gone in to dive into this the
reason why I am one of their paid
subscribers it's not because I use this
to solve my work but because I'm every
few days poking things I need to go and
see what can I do and I have become
increasingly worried about the future of
our next generation
because we're all laughing at this thing
saying hey you know it's pretty good oh
I made a mistake
if you go to really an average middle or
high school student
you don't have trouble performing
at this level
okay and then I I've talked to people
and they said oh but come on chat GPT
won't be able to solve International
math Olympiad problems and I explained
how many people need to solve
International map Olympia problems the
moment when the AI can do everything
except International math Olympic
problems what about jobs so by the way I
also work with people from all over the
world so in the work that I do I'll soon
move into talking about what we're doing
about all of this but in the work I do
we work with people from all over the
world and we have a lot of people from
the Philippines that we work with I
happen to be on a phone call last week
with our our collaborators in the
Philippines and they told us the sad
news that very recently some of the
large Outsourcing companies were laying
off ten thousand people
you know we always talk in the United
States of well you know it's going to
take away jobs it's kind of abstract
tests that it takes away jobs there are
populations in the world where vast
numbers of people do text based
Communications actually even based on
written chat and if the company has the
entire record of all written chats in
the last two years in customer service
you could train a large language model
on that entire body where have it okay
I'm sorry I thought I was giving up I
have to be careful of giving a general
public talk or looking at various people
in the audience but when you go and
build this technology which can go and
pull in and learn from the patterns in a
big body of customer service work you
could actually replace the people
and that's actually what's happening now
in entire sections of the world so this
is this is real right the fact that we
are losing jobs we're also running into
danger of what about what about things
over here so now I've started thinking
about what do we do with the Next
Generation and if you go and think
what do these models do right the the
things that they are actually trained to
do is to find patterns and to be able to
follow patterns and maybe generalize
patterns but follow from things that
have been done before and then do them
again possibly a little bit more General
that's that's the general way that they
proceed and when you think about how
many of many of our population engage
with education a lot of times they're
being taught to learn a method and
follow the method and we might want to
rethink on whether it's worth it to have
people do this over and over and over
again instead of trying to figure out
one of the things that this should not
be able to do as well which is to come
up with new ways to do questions
the sad thing is while we're doing this
to teach our next population we also
have lots of researchers who are also
it's all right you can be researchers on
it that's not a sad thing but I mean
this is a thing that's happening it's
going to happen no matter what but there
are people who are trying to integrate
the chat the the language models with
logic models to make it so they can even
come up with new ideas so what I'm
trying to say is it is increasingly
urgent that we do something to help the
Next Generation to be able to come up
with new ideas
that is I think one of the pieces that
is going to be harder for for these AIS
to reach so now how do you do that how
do you teach that
well we shouldn't do that just by having
people practice a lot of things if you
if you just practice a lot of things you
won't actually be able to learn how to
come up with new things as well I I come
at this as a practitioner so I actually
go and teach and I teach all different
groups I don't only teach Elite students
I'll say soon towards the end I also
work with students who are
underprivileged who happen to have gaps
in their knowledge base because if you
want to help people you need to worry
about worry about everybody so when when
I approach all of this I see actually
that there are many kids who are not
used to coming up with their new idea
and in fact have gotten to the point
where they think that mathematics is all
about having someone already tell them
how to do it and then they follow so
okay if you want to teach this the way
that many of us faculty probably teach
and definitely how I teach is that we
often will will not tell you how to do
the problem I mean I actually I still
teach at Carnegie Mellon University I
tell the class on Monday I'll teach
another class on Wednesday that's why
this talk is on Tuesday
and it's in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania not
Pittsburgh big Point uh so so anyway I I
will teach you this classes and whenever
I teach the past I'm an old school guy
that's why you might have seen I don't
have slides I don't know how slides work
I don't like slides I use chalk hug a
Romo to be specific but anyway so I use
chocolate when I walk into a classroom I
just go in with a piece of piece of
Chuck and I say we got
we got this question or this Theory I
teach a theoretical past this semester
here's a theory we'd like to prove this
theorem does anyone have ideas and then
we brainstorm some of you have been in
that class before so then we have the
students just brainstorm how do you
solve this question and my job as the
instructor is to use your ideas to solve
the problem
this makes it more entertaining for me
I think it makes a better learning
experience for the students too that's
the Hope right but it makes it so that
the students find out that they are
capable of solving any question even if
they've never seen it before because
that's every single day's experience uh
by the way the proof they come up with
is some wacky thing that I didn't expect
would work but it works okay and then I
show okay now another proof and the
student says oh this other idea now we
got another proof also not what they
wanted to show you but it also works
finally we show you my group but my
point is what we always do when we teach
when I teach my class is that I want
students to find out that they are
capable of coming up with their own way
of solving a problem and this is not
only in college I do the same thing with
middle school students you can do this
with all kinds of students the sad thing
is that if you're talking to students
who aren't used to this sometimes the
students say you're not doing your job
you're supposed to tell me how to do it
you're not teaching us anything well I
mean what I'm trying to say is
that's not true it's much harder to do
what I just said
because I have to actually be awake
and
the idea is that I don't think will work
usually do work
this is the funny thing that I've
learned and that's why I write down all
the students ideas and somehow somehow
it works okay so this is actually this
is actually how a lot of us would do
coaching if you ever do after school
math coaching you will find that this is
the way that you teach students at this
moment I also want to say I want to be
careful I'm not trying to criticize
Mainline Educators because we need as
many of them as we can have and they do
a very difficult job and by the way this
teaching style that I just described
does not work in a general classroom I
know because I go to General classrooms
it works at Carnegie Mellon University
it works in any gifted student gifted is
a bad word don't like that word it works
in any math club where people have all
agreed they want to think and when you
go into an average classroom and you say
hey everyone let's brainstorm
20 of the people brainstorm 80 of the
people watch the other people brainstorm
I'm just explaining to you this is what
happens this is the reality okay and so
by the way that's why when you teach in
a regular classroom you do need to go
and find a way to have people do things
I actually don't see an easy way to
change that piece however
if you want to teach people how to think
of a new idea you could pull out people
who actually are interested in trying to
brainstorm and give them a chance to
brainstorm together facilitated by
someone who will show how their ideas
will work this is called math team
and in fact I was fortunate I went to a
public school in Madison Wisconsin my
parents moved away from Berkeley when I
was like three months old or something
so I wasn't really here but I was in
Wisconsin public school and it was the
math team that saved me and discovered
let me discover that I could actually
solve new questions because there were
these people who wanted to try harder
and we weren't smart
we were just the ones who wanted to try
harder and someone came along and
facilitated all of this and that was
amazing unfortunately not every
school in the United States has this
we'll get towards that by the end of
this talk too because I'm I'm going to
be talking about a scalable solution
soon
okay so however oh yes sorry yes
yes that
you know in addition to the years we
write it's called the test message
so what you're saying is maybe you could
try to automate this exact thing by
having to also get improved ideas right
so you basically want a translation
there that takes the ideas that students
are saying turn them into the logical
pieces and then have the thing put
together in logical pieces and feed it
back at the students
it deals with the problem of the teacher
having to be awake yes
so by the way there are two ways to
attempt to solve this problem right so
we're both now we're both thinking how
do we solve this problem because it
would be optimal to give the students
this kind of a dynamic experience one
way to solve the problem is to attempt
to do it while also putting all the
teachers out of work
there's another way to do it which
involves having people do it so um I
happen to be on the employing people's
side so so I I agree with you that in
theory it could be very possible for a
Silicon Valley company to come up with a
way to attempt to do this whole thing uh
and then not have to have people
involved
I'm personally not interested in doing
that so I will let someone else do that
and eventually make us obsolete that's
fine with me but in the meantime what we
will do is we will try to have as many
people involved as possible and also as
I explained this approach you will see
there will be a point in this where it's
actually quite hard to have the computer
do an important piece which is helping a
student feel loved and feel like they
have a future that part we'll get into
this soon too because there's actually a
lot of psychological aspect to this too
uh and you know we have another 25
minutes and so as I keep going I will
agree that from the pure like delivery
of the of the logic that is there but
maybe to do a fast forward one of the
things that I've seen especially since
my work these days also involves working
with underserved students there's
actually an entire Gap that needs to be
jumped when it comes to reaching people
who don't have parents who have been
telling them since they were one day old
that they need to be really good at
mathematics
there are parents in the world to tell
the kids since they are like one year
old but they have to be good at
mathematics and there are also other
parents who don't but at the same time
sometimes those students not just
sometimes those other students have
potential too and so then there's a deep
question of where do you add this
interpersonal piece we'll get to this
okay but what you're saying actually in
theory would work I actually do believe
there are people at my University who
are trying to latch together these we
have we have people doing what is it
there's this there's this there's this
automated Theory improvement work at
Carnegie Mellon University business
language what was that
I I should know this but
anyways
so there are people who are specifically
working on these languages so that you
can go and do automatic theory improving
so in theory yes you should be able to
marry these too I guess I I guess I
should also say to me maybe I'm fast
forwarding again to something else but
when I see what do we need our next
Generation to do I sort of have come to
the I've come to the point where they
have to come up with new ideas and they
also have to learn how to be as human as
possible
we will get to that point soon too it's
like what what what does human mean
because in some sense okay maybe I'll
say it now because in some sense uh one
of the things that I liked doing when I
was doing that was the fact that the
question is clearly specified and then
the answer is a clear function from the
input to the output and those made me
the most comfortable when there was a
clearly specified problem those are also
the easiest to automate but the
interesting most interesting and hard
problems in this physical real world are
the ones which are really fuzzy on the
what are the parameters you're trying to
optimize anyway and how do you balance
this ethical Thing versus that ethical
thing and did you realize that it might
have this other impact those are very
fuzzy and so in some sense if you can
learn to love and do well in the fuzzy
problems well then that's going to be
something that will still be harder to
automate so again we're getting to this
human piece and you'll see soon as I
talk about the solution there's a lot of
human peace inside it because that's
what we're trying to build up okay but
so back to this idea so we're trying to
figure out a way to teach people how to
come up with their own ideas and I'm
trying to do this in a way which can be
done today and also yeah which can be
done today that's the important piece
and the difficulty of course is I've
just said if you want to add more
classes this is not replacing school
because as I've said earlier in the
normal school you cannot just do this as
a replacement for math class because you
might have 80 of kids doing nothing so
okay you need to add more you know we
already have a teacher shortage
so if we already have a teacher shortage
this doesn't work we have to scale this
and in fact in the past most people in
this space were always trying to scale
this with automation like coming up with
algorithms by the way Khan Academy
recently announced that they are working
with uh openai to attempt to make a
totally automated tutor for teaching you
the routine stuff so this is what people
are doing anyway in Silicon Valley but I
actually came up with another way it's
actually very different
and the way that I approach the world is
I think about the world through the lens
of Game Theory so I like to come up with
ways to solve problems where you think
about incentives of lots of people and
somehow align all the incentives so that
everyone does the right thing this is
actually analogous mathematical proof
except that you're not writing logical
statements you're thinking about how
people interact so I need to solve this
problem and I also realized as I was
going to actual schools that the age you
really want to hit this on is younger if
possible
preferably sixth grade or younger
younger is hard though because they
might not sit still so sixth grade is
sort of where we realize you need to go
okay so we want to teach those
and the way I came up with that came
from solving another problem at the
exact same time so there was another
problem I was thinking about you see I
work with the country's top high school
math students
and
it turns out that they have a problem
too
they're trying to get into college
and it turns out that if you're very
good at math
one of the biggest challenges to getting
into a top university is not your math
skill nor is it how many APA exams you
have nor is it whether you got also a
perfect score on the computer
programming Olympiad nor is it whether
you got a Linguistics Olympia perfect
score or chemistry whatever
actually usually around
personality
communication skills to be to be
specific so actually there's a lot of
people in the country for which their
math is amazingly good amazingly good
and if they could lift their
communication skills and interpersonal
skills to the next level they would be
even more successful not just in college
but in everything
so I started a program for high school
students what we do is we bring in
people who are really good at math they
can do any middle school math contest
problem like no tomorrow there's a lot
of these people by the way a lot of
these people maybe many of the people
who work here were like that when they
were in high school as Juniors 11th
grade
and then what we do is after we have
these people I hire professional
Comedians and actors and actresses to
teach them how to be interesting
[Laughter]
because I did this too
so about five years ago I was trying to
get more people interested in math
around the country I was supported by
the overdeck Family Foundation it's a
philanthropic foundation and they
they got me a PR agency to work on
communicating math out to the US public
and the first thing the pr agency told
me is that
you have a big problem you don't know
how to talk to normal people all you
know how to talk to are math nerds
they actually told me that so they said
you need to take
performing arts classes
and so I did it was one of the best
investments of my life
they only cost about 15 an hour I'm
strongly recommending this by the way
improvisational comedy classes
improvisational comedy classes 15 bucks
an hour maybe because of inflation 20
bucks now but um after doing this I
spent for an entire year I was doing
these classes for about three hours a
week and by the time I was done I never
had to prepare for a single lecture
again in my life
it saves more time than you spend
it's actually true this is this is what
I discovered because it would give you
the ability to use your domain knowledge
to then dynamically run every single
class every single experience to match
whatever the audience has
that's actually what you learn in this
by the way I'm strongly recommending
this for anybody in Academia it actually
is it's a time saving it's a Time Saver
I got a few other things too okay and
now we teach all of our high school
students this
this by the way is very helpful to them
we can already see it because the ivy
league admission decisions came out last
week Thursday
and we can see a correlation based on
the small data that we have so far that
people who actually have both the math
ability and some really strong
performing arts training
somehow they're really good at
interviews
actually they're not only good at
interviews I have high confidence that
they will be extremely successful in the
world extremely because these are people
who have both the intellectual power and
they have learned how to listen to
people and read people and make people
laugh at the right times and get their
idea across actually when I was talking
about this at an event that had the
mayor of Pittsburgh in it
um somebody came up to me afterwards and
said
you are creating a generation of
extremely dangerous people
because they both can think super fast
and they could pitch any venture
capitalist build any team
get any philanthropy they want and go
I said yeah that's true that's why our
first admissions point for this high
school program is you have to be a nice
person
actually we do this we have several
criteria in order to get into our high
school program you have to get in you
can't just pay us it doesn't work
actually if you get in we pay you I'll
get to that soon but so so the point is
for this high school program we have a
very stringent admissions process and
it's not that you have to be an amazing
comedian but you do have to be nice and
that's because of you know we are
thinking ahead of this and also because
when I see people who do the latest and
greatest in development developing
technology I see so many students at my
University who are going to be at the
Forefront of developing technology I do
think it's very important that everyone
who gets powerful skills
also has this strong sense of what will
you do with those skills I think this is
actually a very important Point anyway
whatever so we got this thing so we have
this high school program and by the way
this works because it turns out that now
everyone wins in this circle
in the sense that the drama people
we give them jobs
it's great
because it turns out that there are a
lot of people in the Performing Arts
industry who are trying to audition for
Hollywood roles and Broadway roles and
while you're auditioning you need to do
something
you pay your bills
as I said I'd like to talk to people to
learn what your life is and what you do
and I found out that there were people
who have great drama skills and they're
driving ubereats
because you need to do something right
while you're auditioning I asked how
much do you make from ubereats
okay we beat that repeat that that's
that's easy okay so what I'm trying to
say is that we we now have this this
ecosystem running on this side now how
do the two connect this is the point
where finally everything goes through
because so far I don't have a connection
I don't have a I don't have a
self-sustaining machine until you
connect them across suppose you actually
want to learn how to communicate and to
be able to talk and to make people if
you want feedback on your expressions
you need to
talk
you can't just watch an expert
what do you think people who are really
really good at math are happy to talk
about
math
bam this now runs
live video math classes
like what the world has never seen
before let me show you what these look
like okay so I'm going to now I'm going
to show
you what we have actually turned this
whole thing into because I'm actually
talking at the theory seminar here but
I'm actually a practical guy I make
things so I'm not going all the way to
the
it's not just an idea it exists and I'm
going to show you a one minute video
clip snipped just randomly in the middle
of one of our Zoom classes
Zoom classes because the only way to be
able to do something like this at Large
Scale across the world is to use the
internet
wait
Zoom class
did you guys like Zoom class
that was a two thumbs down for lots and
lots of people
Zoom class
I didn't even know if anyone was paying
any attention
okay and furthermore it was hard to feel
like you were there well let me show you
what this student class looks like and
you'll see two people teaching the zoom
class the two people are high school
students I'm gonna geek out soon over
the the incentive alignment of how all
that was built but there are two high
school students teaching this class
you'll see them on screen a boy and a
girl they are by the way both insanely
good at math like their their math
achievements are at like very good in
their State uh and you'll see how they
talk and so on you won't see any middle
school students in this video they're
who they were teaching for privacy
reasons it's because we don't want to
show images of the people we're teaching
to the general public however in every
class those people are also popping up
on the screen so you'll see the
interplay between two of the high school
instructors and this is just a random
clip in the middle of a class for one
minute and this is what we've turned
Zoom class into minutes later
so as we were saying they still meet at
the midpoint that's a great Point by age
and then now I'm seeing this since they
go the same speed this the green one
goes here at the same time the red one
was there
and then 20 times two gives you 40.
because if it takes 20 minutes for green
to go here from the first one to the
right one at 60 miles per hour 20
minutes is 20 miles and then this is
also 20 miles so we get 40.
awesome oh I mean ought to do anything
else that I think that's a really good
Solution by my age yeah it's really good
and one of the better things about that
solution is that you actually don't
really need to know how fast the trains
are traveling you can just use the
Symmetry to sort of yeah so yeah
I actually like that you point out
symmetry because symmetry is always cool
to see and I think
being able to see it in problems like
this makes it more fun and also like
makes it more elegant I guess
but without further Ado Professor is
there another way to do this problem but
I promised you that there would be
another way to do this question as well
that's all we've done to zoom class
we are able to produce Zoom classes live
at enormous scale across the entire
world which all look and run like that
taught by people who know the math like
the back of their hand because any of
you who have ever done math competitions
know that you're used to looking at math
competition questions with the first
glance and having to think
right away
and so what we did is we brought in
people who are high schoolers who
already had that skill so the domain
knowledge is there and then the
Performing Arts aspect well there's one
piece in this whole ecosystem that is
the one that put the final incentive
alignment inside we are the only people
in the world who realize you can run
Zoom classes or we don't need to turn
the lights down that's that's okay oh
that was accident doesn't matter so um
we so maybe if you can unlean on that
that would be great oh okay it's the
best fact we'll fix it another way but
in any case we'll pretend that was on
purpose but in any case uh what we have
is inside every single one of these one
of these classes we have the basic unit
which is two high school students
teaching and we have a drama coach in
every single Zoom class
because there are enough Performing Arts
people out there
in every single Zoom class that we run
there are two high school students and a
Performing Arts person you know what
that does and by the way that is the
piece that then in the math proof
connects everything together because now
here's why everyone wins middle school
students they got this now
the Performing Arts person also makes
sure it's entertaining
Performing Arts person is not a math
expert at all they are in an emotional
expert they see the faces of the
students learning they see the faces of
the people teaching and they figure out
how to match input and output to make
everyone have a good time does that make
sense it's entirely possible and those
people by the way are experts at emotion
what I've learned by working with people
in the Performing Arts world is that I
may know things about The Logical side
but there are people who spend as much
time thinking about emotions as I do
about logic
we have a lot to learn from that so we
haven't and then they come in and they
teach and so now by the way I'll get to
you in a moment and then the other piece
of incentive alignment is for the high
school student you know what you get by
teaching one hour of this class it's not
for community service
you could if you want to be a nice
person maybe you could think that way
but we've actually given you the world's
most efficient way to get one hour of
coaching on your smart
and your delivery
and your posture and your ability to
magnetize you put in one hour you get
one hour back does this make sense like
that that's this is a thing which if
you're a high school student and you
would like to figure out how to improve
your ability to communicate well you
should hire somebody where how are you
going to find them we've just managed to
make the whole thing available at scale
there was a question over there so just
in this example can you give us a sense
of how the Performing Arts person would
intervene okay in this example here's
what the Performing Arts person does
first of all as you can see we do a
bunch of technology stuff so there's the
lights there's the drawing on the screen
whatever every high school student has
actually a two screen setup we send them
their equipment equipment can be
amortized the cost can be amortized
because we ship equipment kits all
around the country as high school
students switch up whether they're in or
not so we have an entire inventory
that's running across the country okay
but basically the high school students
have two screens one screen they're able
to see the image that they're sending
through just like the weather person on
TV
the weather person on TV stands in front
of a green background and points at
things
do you know what I mean like that's how
the weather forecast works and then they
look and see what they're sending to the
other outside world so these high school
students they can see the big merged
image that they have to do that because
when they're writing in the air they're
not writing in the air they're
compositing an image and they're sending
that out by the way I think high school
students see what they look like as they
talk to other people it's actually
pretty useful if you're if you're
watching that thing okay that's one side
the other screen there is a feed
directly from the actress or actor
because the actor and actress actor or
actress is inside the zoom room with the
camera off and microphone off so the
middle school students don't even know
that she's there this is an important
detail we're using everything about the
internet to put in things that couldn't
be done before if you put the drama
queen in a normal classroom no one's
going to watch the teacher okay you're
gonna watch the drama queen but so what
we have here is that another person's
hidden except that there's a parallel
video call going on on the other screen
where the drama person their their face
their smile their gestures are visible
as well as their text written chats
these days high school students are used
to processing enormous amounts of
streams of text coming at them
it's true and they are they are they're
very good at looking at videos changing
uh faces here it's true and then like
all this text coming in so while they're
talking there's text comments coming in
from the from the drama expert and then
if you noticed there was a time when I
showed up
I'm not live
you can't scale me to be in every single
class that we're running but the way
they put me in is the same way that live
television news works if you watch CNN
when they say yeah now let's go to John
our correspondent in New York City that
was tipped
that was taped do you know what I mean
like John is not recording this right
now broadcasting from New York City he
picked an hour ago an hour ago so
actually our high school students they
all have the library of videos that they
will put on of me and they know the
first sentence of every video
so that's why he said Professor Lowe can
you show us another approach to this
question
and oh yeah let me show you another
approach this
we're using that we're basically using
the entertainment Industries tricks to
do mathematics education if you know
what I mean like basically by the way
the reason I thought of all these things
is because my University CMU we are very
good at technology but we also have one
of the top drama schools in the country
if you didn't know before just remember
that Carnegie also made Carnegie Hall in
New York city so if you ever come to
Carnegie Mellon University of this weird
experience where there are incredibly
good tech people and Incredibly good
Performing Arts people
because we have both sides so I just
thought okay let's bring all that in so
now suddenly all this is coming across
while I'm on screen then
she the performing arts expert unmute
entirely and talks in the audio Channel
giving all kinds of feedback on the last
thing that just happened my video by the
way shows up every approximately four
minutes playing for two minutes
by the way the high schoolers they have
a track the high schoolers they don't
have to prepare for the class at all
this is a very important detail when you
when you align incentives these kinds of
high school students have no time no
time so all they do is five minutes
before they class pop on the equipment
make sure everything works and when the
class starts they play the first video
oh they say first they tell the class
hey professor what are we gonna do today
press play oh that's what we're going to
do today
okay and then and then their job is that
they facilitate the discussion because
remember the whole point is the middle
school students come up with ideas so
they they make the ideas work when
they're done they say professional are
the due to the problem okay my video
shows for three minutes then it goes
Ding and the new question shows on the
screen and they say hey here's a new
question everyone let's think about this
one
an hour later the High School student's
job is done we have made it so that the
excess time is approximately 10 minutes
and the one hour dose in the middle is
your access to a professional Performing
Artist
you see the incentive alignment the
point is we made it so that you don't
have to prepare for a pass you don't
have to do anything other than did you
want your dose of a professional oh sure
just go and do this and by the way we'll
pay you too
that's because we have to be legal in
the United States if somebody does work
you have to pay them so okay we pay them
too
the reason the entire thing works by the
way is because now now you can see the
Thruway this is a completely incentive
aligned ecosystem there are actually
enough high school students enough
Performing Arts people how many high
school students are there let's talk to
size this let's size this to see how
practical this is well let's just first
think how many people every year are
trying to get into Harvard Yale MIT
Princeton Caltech Carnegie Mellon
Dartmouth Johns Hopkins University of
Chicago Duke University of California
Berkeley
well there's a lot of people there's
actually I estimate approximately 100
000 high school students out there for
whom this would be a very good thing for
them to do maybe this won't help them
all get into these Green Schools but
they'll give them some some very
valuable skill
and the important thing is they know
enough math to teach people
by the way you also don't need to have
tons of people teaching the few really
good really good students you can
actually go and spread this whole thing
out so you might have the top point one
percent of the people teaching the next
one percent and so on and if you
strategically lay this out you could
actually do a whole lot of damage sorry
I mean in a good way right you can you
can actually have you could have a
hundred thousand people contributing to
this that's how big of a size I see
there is in terms of the high school
group uh by the way that also happens to
be on the same order of magnitude as the
number of people who participate in math
competitions like math counts AMC so
these numbers are not just like me
pulling them out of anywhere they are
actually based on what we see in terms
of the numbers of people out there who
are at this level okay the ratio is ten
to one by the way ten to one in the
sense that the for each High School
we've got 10 middle school so we could
potentially this thing something that
could potentially scale to Millions
that's pretty exciting because now we
have a sudden another another group that
we can bring in and the number of
Performing Arts people you need for that
is on the order of magnitude of a
thousand
fair enough
so when you look at this this is just a
different way to scale everything so
that everyone actually wins the way that
we know this works is because it
actually started blowing up so I've done
a bunch of things in my life and most of
them didn't work because that was before
I realized you should dig things that do
what people want uh but this this
concept came to me in uh in October of
2021 and and I've been working in this
space By the way for about eight years
before that on all kinds of things that
didn't quite scale in education and
finally I got this idea and it's like
when you come up with a math crew again
because I'm actually a theoretical
mathematician once you come up with a
math proof you know that actually every
piece
every implication works it's airtight
and as soon as I saw this thing was very
tight I said okay let's build the
technology so I started building the
technology and the things started
scaling at this point we have 100 high
school students it's a year later it's a
year of advertising students we have
over a thousand middle school students
who have been going through this thing
the thing is continuing to grow at the
speed of people finding out about it
because basically where this fits in is
that there are actually people believe
it or not who are parents of middle
school students looking for enrichment
classes if you drive down to the South
part of the Bay Area you see these
classes everywhere right so this is a
known Market basically what I said is
there's a known Market out there we
threw this into the market
and so actually the reason why we can
run everything is because even
economically it makes sense the known
Market has a known price for the thing I
just showed
and what we did is we undercut the price
and we increased the quality and so at
that point everything starts to grow
naturally now when we talk about what is
this actually adding I agree that an
artificial intelligence could give all
of that feedback and so on but if you
notice what else we have told our high
school students to do
is to show love to show care to
encourage to make people really feel
like being there actually we always tell
them you're a game show host this is
also good for the high school student
the amount of confidence it builds in
somebody who might not have been the
super cool person at school
I wasn't okay if you give them a chance
for an hour or two a week to be the star
then they get used to actually feeling
confident so so this is actually adding
the value there there's other stuff that
this is doing there's more incentive
alignment stuff to geek out on why did I
put two people there I put two people
teaching every class because I'm a graph
theorist and the definition of a graph
is that you have a bunch of vertices
which are the nodes and you have a bunch
of edges which are called pairs of
vertices that was me geeking out over
mathematics but basically the concept is
if you make the basic unit to always
include two high school students
you make friends
this is solving another problem the
other problem is there aren't enough
spots in the ivy league universities for
all the students that we're working with
the scale that we're aiming for is such
that we cannot promise everyone you'll
get to Ivy League and anyway why do you
have to go to Ivy League that's just
like some ancient thing that there were
some some schools which played football
or something like that right so what
you're really about is you want to get
into some ecosystem where there are
other people who trust you who know you
well enough who at some point when you
run a job will recommend you
so I said well you don't need to wait to
AJ team to go to some physical building
covered with Ivy to build that Network
what if you spend a few hours
co-teaching with somebody and you build
a graph you build a network where we are
intentionally connecting the person in
Nevada with the person in Ohio to teach
for 20 hours when you teach for 20 hours
with somebody else you are not competing
with them in the old school math
competitions which I did you would go
and you would meet someone else from the
other state and you each have a buzzer
and one of you will die every one of you
will lose you you know what I'm talking
about everyone you eliminate one of them
so you're you're nervous right so you're
nervous but we did is you work together
we're together and if you work together
you build a friend and you're defending
against all these Middle School students
so that's what we're doing here and
I'm going to go to q a before that I
just want to say there's a full arm of
this which is scholarship related to
like the point is I just described
something which actually can be used for
anything but we have a heart so we
actually also care about the underserved
there's a whole other arm of this where
there are students who don't have
parents who are enrolling them in this
so we've gone and talked to
philanthropists and so actually there
are people who have donated classes they
basically purchased classes and what we
do is we go out of our way into title
One's group these are schools with high
fractions of free and reduced lunch to
specifically recruit classes of high
motivation low access students our very
first class actually started yesterday
yesterday evening and so if there are
people here who work with underserved
schools in the Bay Area if you happen to
have connections I'll be happy to talk
to you it will cost them nothing
and what they will get is they will get
the world's some of the world's highest
quality trained in both math and in
Performing Arts coaches to go and help
them be as successful as possible
thank you
yeah
I wanted to leave enough time for free
ranging q a because that's way more fun
so I see lots of questions was there one
back here I thought I had seen one back
here and we'll go there too so
um yeah let's go there so um
even though I'm a mathematician I chose
to teach entrepreneurship for engineers
because there's a lot more flexibility
and if somebody doesn't get the right
answer you can work with it and do it so
I really enjoyed it the one missing
element from your story is stories I
tell all these stories I grew up in
Silicon Valley so I knew Steve Jobs and
we built an app for one and so that fits
people really intrigued especially at
the young age especially when they say
oh how do you know these these people
are and then you tell the story I mean a
lot of the great inventors but there
were four things that I look for that I
can tell you what the likelihood of
success is in the initial class one of
them was if you were a kid did you try
to read the encyclopedia Trevor to cover
no at least with Elon Musk and all so
there's all these factors that go in so
you want to kind of get them excited but
the story elements are very crucial
because they'll remember the story and
then they'll remember all the techniques
to go with it yeah I think that's great
so what you just said is the
storytelling element is a great way to
get kids to suddenly electron to
something by the way our high school
students to reduce that too they might
not know Steve Jobs
yeah yeah but what happens what we do
see is maybe the stories will be about
some cool math thing or some cool
experience they had if not this is
actually why we give them the
conversation of Comedy training
improvisational comedy sets you up to
randomly tell the story at any given
time and then pull back onto track so
actually the the flow that the high
school students get is they just know
that there are these particular videos
which will get you back on track and
they have the time points to do that in
between they can carry between by either
using the idea students have or if they
see the need to do the story thing they
can do that too
so actually I'll say
basically you're saying there's a good
tactic to use and what we do is we tell
our high school students all these
various tactics that they don't use
their own brain to decide when to deploy
this tactic I'm going to deploy that
yeah
so for instance we worked with this
fashion designer Jake Barnes and she
uses snapbacks for practical stuff but
then people that want to be Financial
designers can also relate to that yes
to and I see somebody doing it and they
said I can be like that person yes I
mean that's great that's great advice in
fact I will tell our high school
students that this weekend because the
way we work is I Mentor all of these
people we have this community and
basically went to high school students
in our community we got office hours 50
every single week and whenever we do the
office hours we always go around and
every high school student shares a tip
that they were thinking about this week
about communication or performance or
teaching and by the way that is how we
exchange ideas it's sort of like you
know teachers well actually professors
we don't do that but anyway what we
actually do in our community is we will
intentionally go through and say here
are some tricks that we know and then
that way each person goes and grabs
other people's tricks and so on so I
will show that one at our next meeting
thank you so what do you find that yeah
oh tonight but but what's that so I will
actually be back in okay let me I'll
take another question so uh I'll just
tell you I'm a little bit crazy so you
can find me again
this is what I'm doing so I'll be back I
have to teach it past tomorrow so I
gotta go but then I'll be back because
there's a math competition at Berkeley
I'll be in the Berkeley area on the 15th
um it gets easier to find me around the
country once you get to me because I
don't have class anymore
but anyway uh there was another question
around here yes uh yeah so let's go back
a little bit to your earlier point about
using you know one of the things you
look for is being a good person and all
that so A lot of times when new
technologies are disinvented you have an
idealistic begin and you have like the
promise of a of improving The Human
Condition and then it gets co-opted by
various things like the Technologies
suits for Mass surveillance and
emotional so you have a sort of
dystopian on the menu in the new
technology that comes along I was
wondering what your what your thought is
about in that field oh my gosh okay so I
thought they were gonna ask me how we
are going to protect against our
speakers so I'll answer that one first
that's why we don't take any investors
actually the thing I've just I'm also an
entrepreneur this whole thing by the way
if you are coming from business school
perspective I've just showed you a cash
flow positive
bootstrappable ecosystem where you get
paid before delivery of product
this is called exponential growth does
that make sense so that's what we're
doing and so we don't take any investors
I have the best to talk to me and the
answer is no because I'm crazy and I
don't want somebody who will be on the
board of directors saying I have a way
of saving one percent of your costs by
doing X so so that's one of my answer
there and that's related to my answer on
the other question
which is that whenever a piece of
technology is made whether it's a
company I always am curious what is the
purpose of the companies who controls
the company who's on the board of
directors and what is their objective
that's the question that we all have to
answer as we look at the various
powerful companies in the world they are
not actually necessarily entirely run by
their founders
governance these are all this is
actually very practical stuff there are
entities in the world they are called
companies they have rules There Are
Rules actually follow the report that
their charger or whatever it is and when
you start looking at this then you see
the incentives don't buy the line
because sometimes there might be an
idealistic person who does not control
the board of the directives
uh that's actually why I went through
the effort to build something where I do
and okay now of course I could be an
evil person so maybe that's bad but I
promise you yeah that's what they all
said anyway what I'm trying to say is
like all these other things what do I
think about I think whether it's being
intentionally used for evil things or
not it is practically putting tons of
people out of work right now
right
and so well what are we going to do
about that we gotta think
that's okay so what kind of reception
did you get from your students for your
methods oh
for this thing the receptions I got so I
traveled around the whole world I was in
Hong Kong over spring break I happen to
meet some students who are in this class
one of them told me this is the only
class I will wake up at 8am to do
because the times of difference they're
taking the a day on pass of course
because now there are lots of people in
China and Hong Kong who want to do this
we have open dedicated times for them
the beauty of this system is we just
open time zones and then we say okay
there will be a 21 hour classes at this
time zone uh who wants to join and so
now we're just opening for their time
zone but that's the kind of feedback we
got we got other yeah is that the kind
of question you were asking
what kind of learning outcomes did you
get learning outcomes well it's only
been one year so all I can see is
anecdotally the students who go through
this thing are somehow very able to
think about new ideas which was the goal
we actually are still in the process of
getting research on actual outcomes I'll
tell you why we're doing that we're
doing that because of the scholarship
angle so we by the way already okay I
should put it this way there's already a
market for people looking for these
kinds of classes for those people when
they see this they can already see that
there's an improvement so they can come
in but there's also this entire other
world we're going into which is there
are public school districts out there
which are spending money to try to help
students learn and there are definitely
going to be some outliers in those in
those Public School Systems and so as
our scholarship side grows we actually
have a third party research agency which
is wanting to join
joint means we will they need to get
paid of course right so as we grow big
enough then we will of course be able to
get them paid not by us for
bachelanthropy to analyze what we're
doing and then at that point so the
reason we're doing that is because we
don't want to run Forever Until that's
okay well I just mentioned philanthropy
because we got two arms we've got one
arm which is just purely growing this
thing and helping to have people learn
but I also have actually spent a lot of
my time trying to make sure that this
new thing doesn't exponentially expand
the equity Gap
because I also work in education right
so to me this is also very dangerous if
I put this thing out here and we just
say hey let's just go make Bank uh we
could and then we leave behind a huge
number of people so I'm doing what a
startup founder should not do instead of
running and just making the money I'm
spending my time going to low-income
schools and understanding how to solve
that problem so that we make sure
everyone grows together this is actually
because that's that's why I don't want
somebody in charge telling me stop
wasting your time going to those places
that's what they would say I'll do it
anyway right but the point is now we're
doing that that one hopefully as we get
that to grow we'll get the research and
then the research we actually fully
expect because you see here's what I'll
say I'm actually a professional coach
I've been doing this stuff for like 20
years and so if you've been
professionally coaching mathematics for
20 years you sort of know what
techniques work and you know when you
know when you see something and so what
I basically saw here is I saw that these
high school students with
improvisational company training and the
support of Performing Arts experts could
approximate my teaching staff
very quickly actually one of them told
me he was at a summer camp and somebody
else told him you sound like Professor
Lowe
okay fair I mean the club was fast what
I'm trying to say is like it's not like
I'm the best teacher but I know that the
way I do things is effective and we're
able to very rapidly get people to to
pull this up by combining domain
expertise and Performing Arts that was I
guess the interesting Market is that the
Performing Arts and the domain expertise
rapidly gives you two Dimensions that
span a large space of of of skills thank
you okay I'm gonna always go back and
forth yeah
a lot about getting into Ivy League
schools getting into good jobs
but like very much you ask a question
like how many people you sure are trying
to get into applying schools and like UC
Berkeley schools like that but I also
have a question inside that's asking how
many people trying to get into ID
leagues know their reads for getting
into these schools because we have to
admit that okay for those people in our
audience if you if you know the meaning
of getting into these schools you're
great but we have to admit that a lot of
people were trying to get into these
schools simply because they are good
schools they have good ranking so they
can perform well in their resumes they
can I mean they can probably promise a
good job like especially in Berkeley how
many people trying to get into a CS
major are actually interested in CS not
many probably 99 of people trying to get
it CS major is trying to find a job
opportunity out of CSS they're not
really interested in CS how many people
trying to get into laws are interested
in being an entrepreneur not many maybe
just 75 percent of people are trying to
be a consultant and earn some money and
call it a day and I was asking
especially in an AI era like this method
I don't think it really works because
these people are trying to learn
fundamental stuff and get jobs and these
jobs are those jobs that are really
prone to the buyer because these people
don't have outstanding skills they learn
skills out of pragmatism not passion and
I was I'm gonna ask like what's your
view what's your perspective on this
like how your education benefits can
actually let people have passion not
just to let people adhere to the like
determined qualities the society wants
us to have but actually people go
outside go above and beyond the
affordable standard to ensure we have a
better future no matter how ai's develop
this is a very good point so this is
actually what inspires me to do a lot of
the things that we're doing
I didn't go to it I believe school
myself so I mean when I say this stuff
about ivy league this is part of meeting
people where they are whenever I want to
get people to do things you sort of
first need to talk to them where they
are and then you can convince them to go
somewhere else okay so what we are
actually doing here is
we don't think that you have to go to an
Ivy League to succeed the advice I tell
all of my students is that the way you
succeed is not by getting some famous
debris it's by making sure you have lots
of really good friends who are capable
and you know can go to powerful whatever
who are two years older than you
because then you get a job through them
okay or if it's not two years old then
later on the same age as you and
somebody is doing something and you join
their startup and so on so actually what
I tell everybody is the value of the ivy
league university actually a lot of it
is in the brand this isn't isn't the
network it's that you're in this network
so you're able to get the job and
somebody else says oh I like the name of
that University I wrote hiring because
of that but ultimately those are Brands
and network right but I realized is that
you don't have to build your network
without a small complete graphs
so what I mean by this is that so this
is now showing you how I look at the
whole world I'm actually still a
mathematician underneath when you look
at the island League World and the UC
and the cattle world when I say small
complete graphs it's not really complete
small dense crops it's that there are
these bunch of people and they all have
very strong connections to each other
and then these have strong connections
to each other and somehow enough of them
end up having enough power to help you
get your jobs when I say this you can
also have an end vertex graph for every
vertex that's degree six you can find a
way to just make it so that all these
people from 14 years until 18 years have
co-taught and built strong relationships
with six to ten other people and there's
a theorem in pure mathematics that seems
that if you build a random ground with
random every vertex having a degree D
and the D is bigger than three it turns
out to be bigger equal to three it turns
out to be what's called an expanded
graph that's probably not what we
expected in the general public talk but
the basic concept is that you're you're
connected with your your distances to
all kinds of other currencies become
very very low and there are many many
redundant
so what I said is look I'm just building
a random Network where every node has
six to ten connections which are good
with other people who have been selected
in not necessarily because they are like
doing all these AP exams because they
were nice they were very good at math
and somehow they were pretty committed
to thinking that interpersonal skills
are important these are the three
criteria to get into our high school
program we by the way reject people who
have very strong contest stories that
fail the other two you do not get into
our program for free by having the gold
medal on the international map of it you
do not you have to have all three of
them and so what we did is we said look
let's just build this network suddenly
it doesn't have to be limited by either
these ones
our network is however big it is and the
point is what really is important is
that about these other people by the way
right now I'm counseling our high school
seniors in this program counseling
because they're making the decisions on
College as they saw right but the
beautiful thing is I just explained to
them
you're fine
because you have this network
right so wherever you're going to go
you're going to still be plugged into
this network so the fact that you have
gone and made custom relationships with
people who are on their way to various
positions of power and whatnot then
you'll be okay and also by the way
that's also survive when we run our
weekly meetings it's all about like
these other things you're talking about
the passion having some reason for doing
something so I actually do have an
objective which is to get more people
interested in let me let me put it so
the message I usually tell people it's
also different to a standards I usually
tell people like in our community and so
on
it's very good if you can move away from
the attitude of how do I get stuff for
myself
and move into the attitude of how do I
create value with my situation
that's actually all I think that's why I
do crazy things like sometimes I do
stuff it's unclear I'm getting anything
out of it it's because when I go around
the world I'm just saying how can I make
the most value generated in this system
in here right and I've done this through
my whole life and many times you know
immediate payback but if you just keep
running around say how do I make value
out of this situation by bringing
together different people by adding a
new idea by adding something I know just
add value don't worry about what comes
back to you this attitude by the way I
actually think we'll get those people a
lot private good people love harder
because by the way if you always want
something you know on my way here I flew
here I was sitting next to a netjets
pilot not just private jets right and
that's when I learned like you know
I didn't know how much those things cost
the other bike price range
okay but what what it shows you is if
you say okay I'm going to be rich then
you see the guy over there yes he
doesn't have a private propeller thing
he's a private jet
well I want that too okay you get that
but the guy was telling me about how
they're these bigger and better ones and
Supersonic and whatever and at some
point when you got your private jet
which is the best one you've got to find
out someone else that's an A380
what I'm trying to say is there's no end
to that stuff right so so what I've been
doing actually if you look at this in
this extensive tour I run around the
country telling people about this kind
of philosophy so I'm basically trying to
change this philosophy on a national
scale and I realized the easiest way to
do that was to show up in their city and
declare a talk
I started this after the pandemic
because I've been giving talks before
and I used to come to things like this
give a talk like an audience like this
and after the pandemic I I was so pent
up I really wanted to go out again and I
just decided to play The Traveling
salesperson problem tsp I'm just done
just plot out path through the United
States of America declaring and I go to
places telling students telling parents
all of that message
okay this is just my style but I think
that the more people who say these
things the better and I'm glad you asked
that much let's go over here there was a
question here waiting for all that yeah
I guess it's like a pretty difficult
question but like you talked about like
a very like domain specific people were
like pretty interested in like math and
like more advanced math competitive
fastness but I guess like I think like
perhaps a more challenging and big scale
problem which like of course like heart
soul they don't expect to have a
solution but like what happens to High
School uh what like chat GPT can like do
high schools high school high school
just got completely broken yeah yes
spend enough time talking to actual
teachers that I can see people are very
work just this morning somebody asked me
the question of what are they gonna do
because
kids can use this to write their essays
yeah actually that'd be correct it she
said kids are using this to write their
assets uh she was asking me can you make
a detector I said good luck I mean you
guys here with your computer science no
the better detective you make the more
you never win that game right so
actually it's the solution that most
people have seen to find to this is
called
um do homework now do do evaluations in
class so write essays in class I was
giving a talk in New York City and I was
talking to seventh graders I said GPT
and they said we hate child gbt I said
why everyone else thinks it's awesome
they said because now we have to write
essays with pencil I said welcome back
to the 1990s
so that's what happened right so in the
1990s we did it is there is there still
do you think there's like still a point
for like teaching all this like it's
like another thing which I'm thinking
about is like okay if this thing can do
like what I'm learning or like what
people are teaching is it still worth
teaching it now the question is should
we change all of the curriculum well we
got some people here who have been
working on talking to people who change
curriculum right it's it's very
difficult to do something at that scale
so unfortunately I have come to the
conclusion that I as a single person
will not be able to convince powerful
people who control curriculum to change
curriculum so what I do is I make an
out-of-band solution
that is just better
and then at that point people come into
that and that's why we have to
researchers because the point is once
the researcher is documenting it then
suddenly there might be a question but
if you just try to go in and say you
must change well let me be very careful
of what I said about Patrick it is not
better because it's also the problem
that I said earlier like whether you
have the password people aren't going to
try thinking so what I mean by this is
we have a way of teaching that extra
piece that you are saying is the missing
part which is true and what will we do
with the actual time that's in school
that one is a problem that I have not
yet come up with a proof of other stuff
so uh I don't know yeah
teach the kids prompt engineering so
that's pretty interesting I will say
though when I go into a school sometimes
when people say please be careful not to
show them too much of what you can do
with prompt engineering rgc
because there's a danger that anything
can be used the other way okay let me go
back over to this side there was I was
trying to go back and forth so did you
have a question yeah
yeah assess if like a given high school
student is nice how do you assess if a
given high school student is nice we
take advantage of the fact that most
high school students haven't learned to
be sophisticated Liars yet
okay so so what I need is that you know
by the way there's like multiple stages
you write some stuff first okay that
could be done back to activity but then
at some point then they have to send an
audition video so far they haven't
figured out how to dictate that but so
they have to send an audition video
of some sense of like whether a person
looks like they might be doing this
because their mom said you need to do
this together under college right the
kids are not that sophisticated and then
finally they get to the interview they
interview us with a couple of people
myself somebody else who's a full-time
and then also some high school students
who are actually inside the program uh
by the way they are very proud of the
program so they have to keep Standard
Time if that makes sense it's like this
is like their thing we always like to
give the younger generation the
ownership right so the point is in a
half hour interview
what we can figure out is you know maybe
we'll have a false we could have like
some flaws positives false negatives but
we are able to generally get a sense of
whether or not you care about people
like we ask those kinds of questions
just not always the same question people
don't say do you care about people right
you can actually tell and I want to
emphasize we take people who are quiet
too you don't have to be this like show
person no there's plenty of white people
who are wonderful and those sometimes
you can tell as you start talking to
them so this is a skill this is a skill
to interview for that but then then
actually before they even get into the
teaching part of the program they have
to go and practice for a while in fact
we don't put someone in front of a paid
class paid class means that someone's
paying for the class or that the
scholarship donor is paying for the
class does that make sense okay class
means delivering the goods we don't let
them do that until they're checked out
on like being able to do what you just
saw here they have to be at this level
where I can go to anyone and say this is
the best life video laptop you've ever
gonna see that's actually what I said
and then we deliver it okay by the way
part of doing that class is you'll come
across as a really nice person so
for me someone can get past this by
being such a good actor that they can
even end up teaching a class to look
empathetic and care about the other
person and at that point okay
but the number of people who are high
school who could get all that far it's
hard usually when they say nice I also
don't think people are fundamentally not
nice I just think that people haven't
thought about that I think a lot of
middle schoolers are just like doing
their thing High smooth their parents
told them to do this and that and then
there's a certain point of maturity when
you say you know what I actually didn't
care about it
right and the other reason why we're
doing this is building a new normal
among the high school math students
who are inside our program and they are
well known so people but when I say
they're well known in this high school
math Community it's a network it's
actually pretty small people know each
other they don't know each other know
each other people know who's in our
program and there's a common
characteristic that people in that
program are like
pretty nice people and now they're
getting more successful
so we're trying to make it so that you
know if you're in the high school math
Community it's not just about being the
best at doing math problems to get ahead
there's this other thing that could also
be important so this is all about social
stuff right and that's why that's why I
go everywhere because that's the only
way that I can think of spread the idea
more questions I'll just keep going for
a few more because oh let me go to the
front now yeah right here yeah so
field
next staff AGI artificial general
intelligence
could actually generate new research
ideas and basically conduct research
because a lot of people there are
researchers and wondering about your
take if that happens that how reliable
things will be how it will affect the
job perspectives of people here okay so
this is about like the artificial
general intelligence taking over the
jobs that people here uh so I'll say
this is definitely not my expertise so
also there are other people that would
know more
um
I think I'll just say this is not
usually what I worry about because the
fraction of jobs in the world that are
the jobs we are talking about right now
is very small so what I'm usually
worrying about is what to do with
everyone else because if everyone else
has no job you might lose your job for
another reason
not that the AI took it but that your
job can't be sustained because people
don't have the money to pay for it so
I'm saying like I think this is a deep
question and I'll leave it for the
actual AI researchers to answer I I do
think we're supposed to be the furthest
away though isn't there some chart
that's the hardest job to remove those
are the research ones so yeah I think
the bigger issue is just I think
actually I'm saying this on purpose
because all of us are also living in
this ecosystem we're all pushing this
ecosystem forward and I do think it's
valuable for us to also think you know
what are the impacts of what we're
making on on on the rest of the world
and by the way we're pretty clever
people you can come up with ways to
mitigate or to assist with that and
interestingly enough that might also
help sustain your position
but again this is not this is not my
main expertise
otherwise I'll go back to that side
again
okay do you see your idea like instead
of like running instead of just math
into like other General subjects for
example like you could use your idea and
use contact videos to put it like in
stream so how would you take the idea of
four okay so you're asking how this idea
by the way doesn't have the only teach
map you can generalize to all things in
that sense I'm not a very good business
person I could but what I'm actually
trying to do here is I'm trying to help
people learn how to think because I
think that's good for them
I could sell more stuff
I don't care
what I think is more important is figure
out how to teach as many people to do
that thinking as possible like for many
years I've actually expressed one of my
goals in life which I don't think I'll
achieved but one of my goals would be if
there could be that half of the
population of this country can solve the
first question on the second level high
school math competition in the US in 24
hours this is called the aimd it is a
math contest where you have a question
where you you don't need to know
calculus don't need no trigonometry but
you need to really think outside the box
to solve it
and actually the goal is the goal I
would have is if half the people could
solve that very first question which
doesn't require any more it often
doesn't even mean high school algebra in
24 hours then we have people who can
think right so my interest is not so
much in seven physics classes it's this
now what we are doing with it though
we're not expanding up that way we're
expanding out in terms of countries
because there's another goal yeah which
is to unite the world like we actually
intentionally are connecting people to
join this program actually I was in
Romania last night
and when I was there I talked to high
school students it turns out when high
school students from Romania they want
to join our high school students they
actually applied in the incentives align
really well actually for them
because for them then they also get to
connect with the US uh the US World if
that makes sense which is also
opportunities so now our program
actually has U.S and Romania now the
funny the interesting thing is this
could actually spam a lot of people and
so I'm actually more interested in just
teaching sixth graders how to come up
with new ideas and how they think with
only
120 hours of class or 200 hours of class
that's it that's it but with that 200
hours of class if we could address all
of the sixth graders in the world and we
did something
with that I think unfortunately we hit
the time so
nice